hey guys welcome to the Evan and Kaitlyn
podcast the show where everything is
made up and the points don't matter okay
okay in trouble on a resume there's a
little bit of a backstory to that but I
have to explain possibly we have been
trying to do an intro for this for the
past two days yes going in circles and
that was the very first thing I went
with and it was hilarious and I just
needed to do it one more time for the
official one okay so we're gonna admit
that you've already use that joke and my
reaction was fake cuz I was trying to be
genuine I didn't know that was your plan
like insert original reaction here I had
a genuine laugh we actually have that we
have that we have we do the audio of it
but we don't have video well I guess not
everyone listening knows that we have a
video for our podcast yet but our
podcast is gonna be audio and video yeah
we we want to give everyone an option of
where to enjoy this wonderful podcast
you can if you can watch it on YouTube
and you can also get it on any of the
standard podcast apps yes such as iTunes
podcast app yeah great plug so what do
you wanna talk about today okay so we're
gonna start with why we're doing a
podcast then we're gonna hit on I think
one thing I've been wanting to talk
about for a while but we didn't really
have a place to do it is kind of talk
about how we've changed and how we're
gonna keep on changing in the future
because it is July 1st January 2019 it's
a new year
a good time to talk about change yeah
it's a good time to talk about change
and in the middle of that we're gonna
sneak in a little bit of a game yeah
okay
so so I guess first off like why before
we get into all the change stuff why we
started this podcast I think the main
thing that
prompted us to start this is one it just
kind of sounded fun but also we didn't
really have a place to share the rest of
our lives because our YouTube videos are
such a small snapshot of our life and
even within the project we have hours of
footage or the project might take days
and we just snip together highlights and
funny moments yeah into like eight
minute video into something that week
there's something that we hope is
entertaining to you guys and there's a
lot of stuff that happens behind the
scenes and I think that it takes longer
to explain that side of things
and making more videos explaining the
behind the scenes would wouldn't be
interesting enough to like take up
watching a video time where a podcast
it's it's like a more background thing I
don't know it seemed like the right
place to put it
yeah I think like for me there's been a
lot of people we watch on YouTube who
have started podcasts or you know maybe
they didn't recently start it but maybe
we discovered their podcast recently and
like one of the things that seems to be
a theme is that the podcast are like a
fun thing that people look forward to
doing and like we you know we've been
guest on other people's podcast before
it's always really fun it's like time
flies by and you're just chatting and
then it's like well we have a piece of
content such a very different type of
content to make as you know as opposed
to the typical thing where it's like
well we have to build a piece of
furniture or whatever I also think it is
a good way to head off potential burnout
I don't want to get into the whole
burnout thing but we've been seeing it a
lot recently I think in 2018 was like
the year and I think that having that
variety having different things to
engage you creatively and allow you to
keep on exploring new things that's that
seems to be a good way that kind of head
that off you segue into our next
change which is changed I guess we're
not fully sure how you the listener
found this podcast we don't wanna make
the assumption that you came from our
YouTube channel but you probably came
from I don't know I think that if I
heard this podcast I would want to share
it with all my friends and family wait a
strong start using a joke but I think
that that I think before we talk about
how we've changed I think that it might
be a good place to talk about what our
original intent was behind starting our
YouTube channel
yeah um well and we've talked about this
a couple places before but don't get
asked it a lot but I think the only
place we've talked about it is other
podcasts oh yeah you've never talked
about it in like an evident Caitlyn
original content I don't know I don't
know how to say that good like because I
guess it's just YouTube videos right now
but now it's a podcast now we have two
places to talk about it so the reason
that we started the channel was because
you know we were both working like
normal 8 to 5 jobs and they're totally
fine nothing like really you know
devastatingly horrible about our jobs I
did work a little bit long hours we did
but at the time we made this decision
you weren't yeah you had already cut
back yeah to normal hours so um so we're
both working normal jobs and it was fine
but like I don't know if it hit you the
same wait hit me and maybe it's
different because I used to freelance
before the job but I just had this
realization of the majority of my time
is spent in an office with coworkers and
not with my favorite person
yes very for those of you who are
listening and not watching I was making
a cute face yes we told ourselves like
okay there's a non-physical humor don't
rely on that you
don't rely on the camera don't assume
people are watching we if something
happens we need to describe it you did a
great job for those of you not watching
I made a cute face yeah oh yeah so we
realized like we're not spending time
with our favorite person how can we like
shape our life to make it so that we can
spend most of our time together instead
of most our time in separate offices and
the first venture that we kind of came
up with was making products together
because we liked making we have some fun
ideas and that eventually through the
documentation of the making we are doing
for that business we are thinking about
starting up doing we started thinking
about what that's what like a lot of
words while we were documenting
everything for the product line that we
were thinking about launching and
working with West Elm we started getting
into social media and we started getting
exposed to the makers on YouTube and we
were like hey let's just start our own
YouTube channel cuz that little bit how
it started kind of well we had a blog
before we did the channel and before we
did products and it was all kind of for
fun and we use the blog to document all
the stuff we were doing to fix up our
house and all of the stuff like all the
DIY projects we were making for our
wedding and so there was kind of that we
already had a little bit of experience
and like making things and sharing it on
the Internet but only like in a hobby
type way we never done it in a like
trying to make it be a business type way
so as we were doing the products I don't
know about you but I started getting
kind of like excited to pick up the blog
again we kind of let it fall behind once
you know when we were both working
full-time after the house kind of got to
a fine point and the wedding was over
and so I kind of got excited about like
picking up projects and sharing them
again because we had started developing
this audience around the products we
were making and it was like ooh maybe we
can double team but at the same time
like the
it felt like an old thing to us cuz we
had already kind of been doing it for a
year or so and it almost felt like to me
like I wanted a fresh start if we were
gonna try to make it like a business
yeah yeah
and that's kind of how we got started
but I think going back to the intent of
it we wanted to make videos about making
stuff but we wanted to be like we wanted
our selves to be present in the videos
and we wanted to grow the channel around
us in the way because we had seen people
start YouTube channels around a single
thing and it seems like they felt
trapped within that thing yeah like
whatever their specific like method of
making was if it seems like some and
sometimes people go down that route and
they are just break it's awesome yeah
but then sometimes people go down a
specific route and they end up feeling
trapped and knowing ourselves especially
me
I'm a little bit like jumping from a
little scattered yeah yeah I am more
focused but I do also get bored like
doing the same thing over and over yeah
so yeah so we knew what the channel we
from the beginning wanted to set it up
so that we could do any type of making
we want and I think since then like
we've been working on expanding it so
that it doesn't always have to be like a
full finished project or something
that's practical yeah you know it
doesn't always have to be a piece you
can just have fun I thought yeah we can
use that fun we can just like make a
water blaster or do an experiment with
potatoes and see if that works and I
think that those are some times the
videos were most excited about where
we're trying something new when we're
learning a new skill when we're making a
new type of video that's when we just
get like super pumped and I think that
that is a great way to stay ahead of
burnout or ardi disagree right because I
kind of think that
lies to every video hmm I don't there
very few videos we've done where I'm
like I know exactly how this is gonna go
because we've done all of these types of
steps before yeah and some of them are
still less fun than others yeah you know
what I mean yeah sure
I think the stuff that I have the most
fun with is when like there's not
pressure there's not too much pressure
on the result of the outcome of the
project mm-hmm you know what I mean like
I don't want I don't want the like
pretty shot of the end product and the
thumbnail to be the thing that makes
people decide they're gonna click on it
or not I want it to be about like
doesn't matter if it works or not
doesn't matter how pretty it looks if it
looks pretty awesome cuz I like pretty
things don't get me wrong but I want the
videos to be more about like the journey
but it's true yeah yeah yeah like
figuring stuff out
yeah it just it puts less pressure on it
you know yeah I think for me partially
what it what it is is trying the new
things too but that you know it works
out that both of us kind of get what we
want through this new approach yeah it
keeps it keeps us ahead of like feeling
like we're doing the same thing over and
over again and burning out yeah well and
for me part of like I like trying new
things too and part of the reason I like
it is because then there's less pressure
like I'm I don't feel like we have to
present ourselves as experts ah
and then again less pressure on like the
final thing being the reason people
watch and don't get me wrong like I like
things to look pretty like when we redid
our laundry room I would have been very
sad if it did good but that was also a
stressful video to do because there was
that kind of pressure whereas like the
first time we started messing around
with resin stuff doing like the geode
slices it didn't matter if it turned out
bad it happened they happened to look
really cool yeah you know you hear a
noise I heard a noise too Jim hey let's
keep on going unless we hear more noises
we don't it Julie you're interrupting
our first
gasps I think one thing that really
helped us figure out what we want to do
though is working with other channels
looking at other channels and getting
inspiration from them I think one
channel that really helped shape should
we go through like a whole list yeah I
think let's go through the list like
this definitely isn't everybody if we're
not mentioning you it's not because you
didn't but I think that I think that I
going through them in chronological
order might be helpful chronological
order in terms of like when we
discovered them as an inspiration yes
okay I think that in the very beginning
two channels kind of inspired our format
Bob but I like to make stuff we loved
how he wasn't stuck within one genre we
like that that he could move from one
type of making to another and the
audience expected that and like that and
we wanted to be able to have that also
yeah I mean that kind of goes back to
what we were saying before yeah but yeah
so that that's kind of what the intent
of what we started it around yeah yeah
um in terms of like the filming and
editing style which is something that I
I thought a lot about like a huge a big
really big inspiration was Casey and I
stat which I feel like like anyone
starting a YouTube channel could
probably say that but just in terms of
like I don't know cool editing cuts and
like keeping the pacing of a story right
and stuff like that yeah I think that
after that start that got us on a good
path we made some good videos and I'm
not fully sure how we found William
Osmond I think on reddit probably on
reddit and then we really enjoyed his
videos and we somehow ended up
collaborating with him and that really
pushed us into a whole new whole new
[Laughter]
warning to say
but like I would have sung it so
accurately Kabhi strike right then are
you saying my rendition was inaccurate
yes but about working with William
working with him yeah like working with
him in person seeing how he filmed
seeing the come along with us along this
journey putting yourselves in funny
situations and just just like leaning
into that chaos that really helped us
open up our videos to incorporating more
humor in a natural way well I think for
me to put a very specific to look at it
specifically is we never filmed things
where we talked to the camera in person
very much aside from like an intro and
did he just do a lot of voiceover you
know we did intro and outro and we did
voiceovers and every now and then there
might be something that we caught on
camera funny moment yeah you're right
wow that was a big shift yeah and after
that we were kind of forced to talk to
her actually to the camera cuz the whole
thing nothing's planned you know we used
to plan out all of our shots we would
plan out our voiceover scripts
that's when funny bloopers and stuff
would happen but for the majority of
video we had skips and I think that was
kind of like a crutch that we lean as we
were starting because otherwise it would
have been really tough yeah I mean it's
hard to get used to being on camera
oh very first video we made all of the
retakes Oh like I think half the retakes
we've ever done we're in that first
video yeah yeah we still spent more time
on that video just trying to do the
intro and outro yeah yeah our very first
video the project itself was adding
knobs and pools to an IKEA dresser which
is the easiest thing God take us like
for like three hours to film now
yeah and it took us that long yeah but I
think that really pushed us in a new
direction and it took us a while to
stabilize after William was after
working with William we we we kind of
went up and down and figured out how to
be ourselves with that new thing I think
it's weird like a cameras pointed on you
and you know you need to be entertaining
but you also need to be yourself yeah
it's hard to be entertaining on purpose
while also being yourself it's a skill
that well I don't know maybe some people
just have it some we had to work on yeah
there's definitely some parts of older
videos I mean a lot of the obvious stuff
I cut but even some stuff is still
stated in older videos like I will
cringe at it so awkward I were trying so
hard yeah yeah but I think that kind of
going along that same humor line we've
we figured out how to kind of be
ourselves after working with William and
figuring that out but then we were in
San Francisco hanging out with a friend
and they showed us Brad lyon from it's
alive from bone Appetit it's like kind
of complicated he is a segment on one of
the channel he doesn't have his own
channel but those videos are so great
and they have a entirely different sense
of humor and it's a lot of words and
overlays and all sorts of things you can
kind of do in post yeah yeah my
inspiration from Brad was like all of
the post editing and how much humor can
be added and just the Edit he was the
first the first of a few to come but he
was like the first that really inspired
us I think that there's yeah he was the
first one where we saw how much humor
can be added in the edit just like the
repetition of things and another thing
that I forgot to mention between William
and Brad both of them have a camera guy
who is a person who is like a
personality and I think that looking at
both of them
it let us from behind the camera be a
character while we're filming the other
person yeah I kind of feel like we were
doing that before though yeah as the
person who was behind the camera more
but I think at this point with all of
these inspirations in her head we were
trying to do everything we were just
filming everything and it took us a long
time to make these videos we filmed a
lot it took a lot of editing and I think
the turning point for us is when we went
to visit Alex do you mean the next
turning point cause I've been turning
the next turning point for us yeah and I
think for Alec I mean we had obviously
already watched a lot of his videos and
were aware of his style and I think one
of the things that always puzzled me how
how how how does he have such polished
videos that they're polished but they
still have a lot of personality
yeah and how does he make them every day
every freaking day and like we knew that
he had editing help you know we before
we visited we didn't know you know does
he secretly have a huge team behind him
at one point I'm like does he have like
there are there three people over there
are there like yeah it's like a film yes
just two people
um but doing our collaboration in
purpose and scene impersonal never being
there and seeing how he filmed that was
the turning point for us in terms of
getting a lot more efficient yeah you're
getting a lot more efficient he films
for what the Edit is gonna be if it's
gonna be slow motion he thumbs some slow
motion if it's gonna be a talking point
he films for that and if it's gonna be a
series of short clips edited into a
montage he films for that he just
doesn't keep it rolling and decide later
on do we fast-forward through this do we
include these sound bites he does the
editing in the moment so in it when the
raw footage gets his editors desk
it's a lot more it says that the
decisions have already been made to some
degree
and I think like when I've said this to
other people they're like well yeah but
I think like for us we were so afraid
that if we weren't filming everything we
would miss a funny moment or whatever
but I think that's because like what we
were going for was that like in the
moment and the moment natural stuff yeah
but we were so afraid that we would miss
something and then it wouldn't feel
natural I wouldn't feel in the moment
that we just over recorded like crazy
and I think like being there in person
and seeing Alec do it like he's
obviously very genuine and himself when
he's talking to the camera even though
he is planned like at this point I'm
gonna grab the camera and talk to it and
that's gonna be the talking part and
then the next scene is gonna be montage
like he could still feel really genuine
so we started trying to do that and got
a lot more efficient with our filming
yeah and with each of these new
inspirations it took a while to figure
out how to apply it to us I think like
we almost went to extreme for a little
bit every one of these extreme and then
it normalize to us yeah but so now our
balance is more like you know we do plan
what scenes are gonna be montages and
stuff but for a while right after
getting back from Alex we only filmed a
little thing I wouldn't leave the camera
running at all for any scenes so it was
only like pre-planned I'm gonna get this
shot and then I'm gonna get this shot
and I didn't want to just leave the
camera running while we figure something
out and now it's a little bit of an
in-between yeah it's gonna in between
like I'm not afraid to just leave it
running and know in my head like okay
yeah after this scene there's gonna be a
lot of footage to go through yeah yeah
but I know funny stuff is gonna happen
naturally and if I just try to keep the
camera off and only pick it up every now
and then we're not going to capture
those moments yeah I think we stay there
for a while at that point and then we
found the try guys and I don't know how
much we've incorporated from them
because they're like a whole new try
guys is a whole another level but I
think we might just say like some what
some of these other channels are cuz if
they're not in the maker community
so we said that Brad is from he does
like cooking shows oh yes Bob from I
like to make stuff we would have a bob
as people knew Casey as people and who
William is okay people knew who Alec is
people who Alec is he's like a
blacksmith awesome awesome blacksmith I
think you want to go through everybody
will go through everybody
bob is maker extraordinaire he makes
everything I don't know how else to say
that that sounds good yeah Casey is a
New York vlogger that vlogs around his
life and specifically his business his
ventures technology and stuff William
Osmond is a tornado of engineering and
bad cat t-shirts yeah he makes hilarious
videos around unnecessary creations
necessary creation I got it
Brad cooks amazing stuff in a hilarious
way I don't know how to say that yeah no
not even around its alive anymore yeah
you saw these stuff that was like
fermented or this or that but he at he's
just a character yeah he's just a
character he's like it dude you want to
hang out with yeah totally Alec is a
blacksmith that makes videos almost
every single day around his shop forging
making the stuff he makes ridiculous
things and he's just super entertaining
yeah okay now we're cut up look at
podcast go get a podcasting the try guys
are for guys that try a whole bunch of
things often embarrassing but the thing
that really inspires us about their
videos is how they're edited how they're
planned
just like the logistics after creating
videos ourselves knowing what goes into
the logistics of their videos is
inspiring I don't know the reason that
they were an inspiration is the lay
ring in there edits you know most maker
videos it's 100 beginning and you end at
the end with the finished product yeah
and you just follow through the steps as
you go with the try guys there will be
you know the task they're trying and at
the same time there's also the expert
there talking to tasks and then there's
interviews with each of the guys talking
about how they think they're gonna do on
that task
yeah predictions reactions and yeah and
then there's you know so there's let's
just keep it simple
yeah there's those three the tasks the
interviews of the guys and the
interviews with the expert and as the
videos being shown to you it's not like
they show all of the guy interviews then
all of the expert interview and then all
of the tasks it's all intercut and inter
chopped in a way that makes it so
entertaining and so good so it's like
what one example is the guys are trying
to bake a bread they're trying to break
baked bread and it goes like it follows
them into the pantry they grab like
yeast and then they pour the whole
packet of yeast into their mix and then
it cuts to the expert thing for yeast
you should only use a little pinch boop
the contrast of that is just so
satisfying and hilarious and like
they're an inspiration that we've been
able to implement the least because it's
very hard we tried with our prop off
video that was inspired by their format
and it was really fun I think it turned
out really good I think this is a big
shift that's that's my thought it's a
big shift in our content never spent
more time on an edit you've never spent
more time it was probably one want to
say how many hours there's a lot there's
like a week straight of editing for full
day every day and all that I did maybe
more than that I love it thanks the last
inspiration this is a reason this is a
recent one I feel like she's been a big
inspiration for you go fart go fart so
jenna Marbles
she is someone who's been on YouTube for
a long time and
we didn't discover her channel for 10
years or something yeah and we didn't
discover her channel until recently so I
can't I can't speak like I am like an OG
fan or anything like but I discovered
her and became a very quick fan but her
she she kind of does like a mixture of
slice-of-life just everyday kind of
stuff and then a lot of like parodies
not really the right word but parodies
what you show me she'll she'll try like
trends on YouTube and just see how they
work usually it's like beauty trends and
stuff like that or like crafting trends
but it's the reason that she's an
inspiration is cuz like the videos are
just super casual and she's hilarious
without trying too hard yeah I think
that's a really hard balance to strike
as being like I don't think we've like
beli laughed so hard as I like outside
of some of her videos you know like and
but she doesn't try too hard she doesn't
try too hard
she doesn't care and she just does her
own thing
no matter what yeah and that is
inspirational
yeah well it's like her whole you know
one of one of her things is like she's
gonna do what she wants on her Channel
she's make videos kind of herself in a
way she's gonna do it wouldn't that's
very inspiring yeah you know and I don't
know if we're fully 100% there yet we
obviously still like it's a balance of I
mean everything we do is something we
want to do but there's ideas that I
would like to do that I don't think we
did on the channels are not gonna do it
you know but we're doing something that
beer video you really wanted to do that
beard video dreams coming true right
there yeah although it totally would but
we also it's like we loved all of this
and basically our channel has changed
over time as we have discovered these
new things and we get excited about them
and we incorporate them and in the end I
mean all of this is a quest to be
ourselves
you know I think that sounds so lame but
it's it's hard to be yourself when you
haven't like fully discovered that
because yourself on video it's like it's
still us but it's the US on video yeah
you know yeah it's like you can't
include everything in the video so it
ends up being like just a portion of
yeah because we're trying to make a
video that's entertaining that is us but
if we were just 100% us it'd be a lot of
us just like sitting around or like you
can't put all aspects of like your
interest or your personality into videos
because you have to keep them more
focused cuz okay for example you know I
I like making stuff so like cooking I
also like cats you know but ever I have
that's just like Susie do you think
there's more than that there's more but
like it'd be hard to have a channel that
revolves around making things and
cooking and cats okay don't let your
dreams be dreams well I mean I guess my
point is the bigger your list goes that
you're trying to include the harder it
is to find people to watch because I as
a person like those things but it's hard
to find other people to have yeah you
know and so if you just have one thing
your channels about it that's making
stuff they just have to find people that
like making stuff yeah and they can like
other stuff in addition but they don't
all have to have that perfect recipe so
I think it's hard to that's why I think
it's hard to like fully include all of
you when you're just doing this one type
of thing yeah and that's another reason
why I'm excited to be starting these new
things where we can express different
sides of ourselves yeah yeah you know
one side of myself that I want to
express I have no idea how I'm going
into the segue I want to play a game
okay guys so one of the things we want
to do in this podcast are play fun games
I'm really selling the first one that
we're gonna play is where we try to
communicate something but only one word
at a time we alternate who says that
word what should we call it it's not an
original idea it's been done before
right ironically on whose line you
apparently they're toggling we're
stealing Swedish replay replay some
intro music yeah alright I'll go first
I'll start off the first letter topic
we're gonna be making workshop safety
announcements these are things that you
would see posted in in like a workshop
about safety never have cats in your
belt because they have claws like a belt
sander or something like that
I wanna like say things are more
open-ended because I'd like gonna say
like here I'll aim on let's do a lame
one ready no I don't like I want to see
if my theory about this lame okay
never eat Sam you start with something
so closed with like never then you'll
say like a verb or something right well
how else do you want me to start it see
yeah yeah it's like I was intentionally
not saying things like that like
No you know I'm gonna start it off one
right I'm gonna do it really good I mean
I already did this one I did win right
yeah the hangar that's such a good
starter before washing your feet make a
[Laughter]
go with our expertise which is YouTube
not really
YouTube's best practices in general no I
almost are never win posting a video
always blend your feelings with okay
that one Subway's weird thank you for
going though
and being so yourself
thank you alright speaking of being
ourselves as we go into 2019 we are
gonna talk about how we might change in
the future
one thing that surprising is with
YouTube which is our main thing I I'm
not sure how much we're gonna change the
main thing is just continue
lean into the lessons we've learned and
continue to be more of ourselves and try
new things but that's that's what we've
been doing I think I think there are
some things that I still consider new
and in the process of changing you're
not thinking about just because it's
already started yeah okay so what are
some of the things so in December we
started doing occasional E&K Tuesday
videos because we we want to be able to
sometimes do more casual stuff like it
was so fun to make they're super fun
like we literally filmed them without
even knowing that they were gonna be
videos yeah we were just like let's just
film like vlogs to practice and then we
ended up posting them so like we're
literally in our PJs I'm not wearing any
makeup or just like acting silly but I
think that's one thing that we don't
want them to replace our normal Friday
videos but we want to be able to do
bonus videos also I think that they help
us explore new areas and new ways of
filming that we can continue to help us
grow any ways of editing to like there's
some stuff that we did in those videos
that like in the edit and stuff that
ended up being hilarious and you had to
did yours yeah most of yours you know so
you had some more editing in too and
then we were able to use some of the
stuff we learned to edit our normal
videos yeah you know so I think it's
it's fun practice but I think that's one
thing is you know it's not gonna be
something we do every single Tuesday we
don't want to have it be a regular thing
we don't have to be a burden yeah we
don't want to be a Breton bonus yeah and
then I think with our video with our
main videos we're gonna continue to just
keep mixing it up in more ways um just
because we you know we already mix it up
in terms of materials we use and stuff
like that but we want to keep mixing up
the format and type of video a little
bit I'm trying to not say any of the
ones we have all you can talk about the
Friday one thank you
yeah okay yeah so we're recording this
on the first is coming out this this
video is coming out this for
the podcast is and in addition to this
podcast we just released a video where I
can just say it
oh but we don't say the result we don't
say we're gonna try we we're gonna test
cooking an egg using only epoxy yes can
epoxy cook an egg and so that's I feel
like that's an example of the kind of
thing that we want to be able to
incorporate our video it's like maker
adjacent it's science adjacent science
adjacent like we do stuff that's
adjacent to the things we already do and
kinda really was something that we were
really curious about we really wanted to
know yeah because we've been doing these
resin epoxy projects and they let off a
lot of heat and you know I wanted to
test it we also wanted it I specifically
wanted to test like how hot did it get
how hot does it get like do we need to
be worried how thick can we pour it and
as long as we're doing that we might try
cooking an egg on it yeah so it's like a
perfectly natural thing to do perfectly
natural perfectly natural another thing
that we want to do this year is start
our podcast look at this just hard day
one day one it is happening after a year
and one month of achieving it yeah
really like trying like not not trying
like waiting until it was right yeah and
telling everybody about it because we've
been wanting to do this for a long time
so long we recorded a test episode we've
recorded a couple but there's one that
we listened to recently to see what we
talked about it in the beginning we say
we're like saying what was going on in
life and I was like so we just hit 7500
subscribers that tells you how long and
we don't even thinking about it for
awhile by then so it tells you how long
we've been wanting to do this yeah so
crazy it's happening yeah so we're gonna
keep on doing the podcast and one thing
that we've also started doing just this
last December is starting to ramp up
twitch a little bit yeah
trying to become affiliates but also
it's an again it's another entirely
different form of creating content
interacting with you guys and it's it's
you'd think it wouldn't be that
different but it's just so different
yeah I mean what's like very casual like
in terms of like casual levels there's
like the video is up here almost almost
polished which is funny and then there's
like the podcast and then there's twitch
which is zero editing zero nothing is
what it is and I think like if I look at
the themes of the things that we're of
like our goals and the ships we're
trying to go through yeah really all of
them are just us wanting to be more of
ourselves the Internet
and it's been great this change has been
so great that we've already gone through
that we're going through right now it's
it just makes us really happy and it
makes me excited to continue to do and
this forever well I think an interesting
one or an interesting thing is it's
definitely made me really happy and
really excited to keep doing stuff you
know just dipping our toes and some of
these changes although like we have been
getting on our recent videos at least I
mean for twitch there's there's no
backlog to compare it to podcast is
brand new on the videos where we've kind
of tested being even more casual leaving
in more of the funny like side mmm
you know tangents that happen in all the
projects we just used to cut them or
save them only for the bloopers
we've been including more of that and
being a little bit more experimental and
the views have not been as high and part
of that is we just had a really insane
month the month before October November
well that's two months back we were
putting out like six or seven videos a
month and because of some sponsor
obligations and scheduling things all of
our big projects were packed into those
months yeah all of them and so it was
awesome because we're getting a lot of
views a lot of subscribers but then
December where we've kind of been doing
of more like better balance of what we
want to do it's been less it's been less
but like less use less subscribers but
even despite that I'm still more excited
and I'm continuing to get more and more
excited so I think that's a good sign
yeah you know is that a good place to
wrap it up we can't just yell by to do
it I can see it in your veins let's
start with some asks cuz this is our
very first one we we want to see how far
this can reach we want to get your
feedback so if you are listening to this
on a podcast app a rate and review would
be great and I think that the only place
you can do that is an iPhone so if you
don't have an iPhone steal your friends
review it on her phone say something
great hopefully and another place to
interact is on YouTube yeah and I think
that's one another reasons oh this is I
meant to mention this earlier another
reason why we wanted to put these on
YouTube is we love the community there
we love people commenting we like people
and everything putting out a piece of
content and not like replying to
people's comments after we do on video
so yes so like as usual with YouTube
like liking commenting subscribing is
all that really helps us grow and it
helps us shape thing that's going
forward and we do want to engage with
you guys and see what you guys like
about this and what you're excited for
us to talk about what you like want to
hear I wanted see on this podcast we
want to hear on this podcast plus if you
go to youtube channel you can see things
that were otherwise poorly describing
like when Evan went like this and said I
made a cute face and in the future when
we do things that require visuals we'll
try to include that in like form
description a little time tag
them well like timestamp them yeah oh
you really will put them on the green
screen and then timestamp um what are
you saying we'll figure it out we'll
figure out well we'll figure out some
way to make it easy for you guys but
really the main thing is we want your
feedback we want you did engage and
we're looking forward to seeing what you
think about what we just created yeah I
think that's as smooth as we could hope
that are out here hey for the first one
that's not bad let's go for it thank you
[Music]
I'm like we're at the evident Caitlyn
podcasts were not evident Caitlyn I
can't just say you got like some red
pepper flakes can we get it yeah okay I
hope the mic doesn't pick up this noise
okay Oh announced isn't my finger yet